Rhianna now your you use your accent in
the film and and but I didn't realize
that your axe that was kind of the
reason why you had your first big hit
that's how you got umbrella because lots
of people wanted that song a lot of
people message all week I've pretty I've
got to ask you any chance of a new album
or anything or have you just walked away
from that who sent you I know one of my
fans got to you Graham no no they
honestly stopped my twitter feed has
just been full of can you use I actually
am in the studio and working on new
music
I mean is there a deadline it's really
given it so much it paid you well be out
in time for Christmas you just have to
wait and see okay I'll come back when I
put it out
that'll be back I do it are you
you're gonna throw me an idea we didn't
do a song together like the video
[Applause]
oh yeah
[Music]